this week on brian ross investigates
the elegant tennessee walking horses
with their high stepping gate called the
big lick drawing big crowds and millions
of dollars in prizes and stud feeds a
proud tradition but behind the scenes
the ongoing ugly secret of how those
horses are scarred and soared their legs
soaked in acid and diesel fuel
so by inflicting this pain on the horses
they get the horses to step higher and
they're rewarded at the shows
this trainer caught on tape beating the
horses pleaded guilty to state and
federal criminal charges and was
supposedly banned for life from being
part of the sport but now he's showing
up at major competitions
and for him to be sitting there is
egregious
we have a say in big lick big lie
plus lifestyles of the rich and infamous
a major investigative reporting coup
documenting of the world's richest
people hide their billions buy their
yachts and take care of their mistresses
we're talking about some of the most
famous people in the world that are in
these documents presidents prime
ministers
government ministers
the pandora papers pulling back the
curtain
and this week's winners and losers in
the media see if you agree with the
choices made by the editors of media
[Music]
from the law and crime trial network
this is brian ross investigates
and good evening and thank you for
joining us and welcome to our friends on
facebook live
i'm brian ross joined as always by my
colleague here at law and crime rhonda
schwartz and rhonda we begin with a
disturbing story about the lengths to
which some people will go to win in this
case the trainers of those famed
tennessee walking horses they've been
caught in the past beating the horses
inflicting pain really torturing them
despite cause for reform it turns out
the practice never really stopped rhonda
that's right brian the humane society of
the united states first documented the
practice but now we're learning that a
ban on those caught in the act and
promises of reform seem to be empty
words
but a warning to our viewers some of the
footage you are about to see may be
disturbing
they are known as tennessee walking
horses famed for their pie stepping gate
called the big lick with billions of
dollars in prizes and stud fees for the
very best of them
but behind the scenes there has been an
ugly secret
an undercover video investigation by the
humane society of the united states 10
years ago documented disturbing scenes
of torture
the horse's hooves scarred soaked with
acid or diesel fuel and wrapped with
heavy chains all as a way to create pain
and an even higher stepping horse
so by inflicting this pain on the horses
they get the horses to step higher and
they're rewarded at the shows
correct
dr bart sutherland a former usda
inspector says the practice continues to
this day we've been into barns where
they've used these chains that they put
around the horse's leg like a bracelet
but they're
they may weigh several pounds
and just the trauma of that
chain hitting on the back of the of the
leg and stuff
will make them pick up their feet a lot
higher i've seen people apply all kind
of petroleum products uh sometimes
they'll
they'll blistering blistering or burning
them or using some type of chemical or
acid to to irritate the back of that
the undercover video 10 years ago
focused on one of the sport's most
prominent trainers jackie mcconnell he
was seen along with two stable hands
beating the horses
he didn't want to talk about it when i
approached him then on behalf of abc
news nightline
you have any regrets about what you did
to those horses he showed no signs of
remorse when we tracked him down outside
his home this week don't you want to say
something about that don't you want to
apologize
don't you want to apologize
mcconnell later pleaded guilty to more
than a dozen state and federal accounts
of animal cruelty sentenced to a year of
house arrest and was supposedly banned
from the sport for life
mr mcconnell has been an abuser of
horses for decades he's now a convicted
felon we're very happy that we have a
felony conviction but he's shown no
remorse for the damage that he did to
these animals countless victims of the
torture that he inflicted upon them
but now animal welfare advocates say
mcconnell is back in good standing with
the tennessee walking horse industry
he was pictured last month at the
sport's biggest gathering the
celebration even though the board of the
celebration had banned him for life
following his convictions
the picture was taken by mississippi
lawyer and animal welfare advocate clant
c i figured we had the document for this
for the world uh jackie is part of the
warping weave of the big league animal
cruelty culture and for him to be
sitting there is egregious it was jackie
and no one said one word about it and
then come to find out he's presenting a
donating a trophy at the challenge
trophy in his dad's name memorial
challenge trophy donated by the jimmy
mcconnell family of shelbyville the
jackie mcconnell family of collierville
will be presented by stacy and alex
blackwood and they said well we let him
in on a technicality he's just a
spectator sir he wasn't just a spectator
he was a participant in the warping
weave the announcer called out his name
he was recognized
so what does that say about the
commitment of the industry of the
community to ban uh this cruelty
we have a saying big lick big lie
sir they're disingenuous to the extreme
they're not truthful
c showed us one of his horses glimmer a
one-time deprived horse that he rescued
from the so-called soaring he was thrown
away he was on the had a one-way ticket
to a public auction to go to a slaughter
truck in mexico and we rescued him
former usda inspector dr sutherland says
while there are plenty of horse owners
who won't go along with it the practice
of soaring remains rampant very few of
those cases get
prosecuted i mean it's
you know a small percentage of them wind
up having any penalty at all in fact
they would they would joke about it
sometimes you know they didn't really
seem to be bothered that we would write
up a federal case in fact there were
some some trainers that had 30 40 you
know
maybe more cases written against them
and had
yet to have a uh
any penalty received from him
and so given that this practice then
continues and they don't have much to
fear
that's correct
it must have been very frustrating for
you
it
was frustrating to to the point that i
stopped doing it
clancy and a group of other animal
welfare advocates are still trying to
draw public attention to what is
happening showing up to protest at some
of the big walking horse competitions it
is absolutely abhorrent
that this scourge
persists it continues that it operates
under this cloak of secrecy by this
cabal that is
showing here tonight there's a lot of
money involved they don't want to stop
their games
this past weekend in north carolina
there are people in the crowd who
weren't very happy with clancy trying to
take pictures with his phone i don't
care if you want me here big boy out of
here
get out of here
i
love my horses i love my mayors
i even love this dude behind me
i'm just devoted to it mr ross i don't
know what else to tell you the tennessee
walking horse should be america's horse
and it just went astray
the tennessee walking horse celebration
told us that jackie mcconnell was
allowed there because he was only a
spectator but that in the future his
name would not be recognized in the
programs or on the public address
systems as the sponsor of one of his
family's trophies they say by the way
that they are leading the fight against
soaring and that the number of soaring
incidents has sharply decreased as for
jackie mcconnell i tried to reach him
today on the phone
can you give me an idea i'm recording
this sir i have no comment no comment at
all about why you were there i thought
you were banned for life i have no
comment
no comment from jackie mcconnell
coming up next a journalistic scoop the
lifestyles of the rich and the infamous
exposed by an incredible journalism
investigative report you're watching
brian ross investigates on the law and
crime trial network
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
we turn now to an amazing investigative
journalism scoop created by a group
called the international consortium of
investigative journalists they got their
hands on a treasure trove of documents
millions of documents showing how shady
financial firms helped to hide the
wealth of the rich and the unscrupulous
this leak is really panama papers on
steroids this is the pandora papers
because we think we're opening a box on
a lot of things we're looking at about
12 million documents from 14 different
service providers these are law firms
and firms that set up secret offshore
accounts for people in multiple
jurisdictions the british virgin islands
belize
samoa
these documents for the very first time
is actually showing the us as a tax
haven itself
we're talking about some of the most
famous people in the world that are in
these documents presidents
prime ministers
government ministers
we're seeing them buying real estate
we're seeing them trading in shares
using offshore companies they're buying
houses cars artworks
i guess it mostly demonstrates that the
people that could end the secrecy of
offshore could end what's going on are
themselves benefiting from it so there's
no incentive for them to end it
and when the stories broke it was big
news around the world and america's late
night comics had a good time with it
what
the rich and powerful have been hiding
their wealth in offshore havens to avoid
paying taxes i am disgusted
and extremely jealous because i'm out
here on turbo tax adding up line nine
with line 37 like a bitch when it turns
out i could have just sent my salary to
some island rich people they're just not
like us
us pay taxes
and we're joined now by michael hudson a
senior editor at the international
consortium of investigative journalist
michael thank you for being here what a
scoop how long did it take to put it
together
uh thanks for having me brian and and
rhonda uh uh about two years um
and it also took more than 600
journalists from 150 news outlets and
117 countries to kind of pull it off i
mean some of our partners included the
washington post the bbc the indian
express
the standard in zimbabwe
and ledesk and morocco and many many
more and a lot of just smart and
courageous journalists around the world
who are operating and
countries where sometimes
doing investigative journalism is
considered a crime
and you learned a lot about presidents
prime ministers kings drug dealers and a
whole range of people who hide their
money they're very very wealthy
essentially how are they doing it and
why are they hiding their money
you know there's a lot of different
reasons and in some cases people are
hiding their money to avoid taxes in
some cases uh people are hiding their
money because it's dirty money it's
money that came from uh
you know the profits from from ponzi
schemes and other frauds or money that's
been looted from a government program
uh you know another thing you know the
king of jordan uh you know we were able
to document that he had bought 15 luxury
homes in the us and the uk
over several years total price about 106
million he also had 36 shell companies
his offshore
providers his offshore advisors you know
often sometimes referred to him and
emails simply as you know who in order
to kind of keep him
behind the scenes but you know what what
the king of jordan's uh folks told us is
look he doesn't he doesn't have to pet
you by law he doesn't pay taxes in uh in
jordan
but but uh other experts said you know
but he also has a very good reasons not
to flaunt his wealth first of all if he
you know if people knew that he had this
kind of wealth and these kind of houses
luxury houses around the world it would
obviously uh
anger many of his citizens but it might
also concern
many of the governments and uh
aid organizations that have been you
know giving his country which is one of
the poor countries in the middle east uh
lots of money over the years so there
there's a whole range of reasons why why
people do this and why people want to
want the protection and in many cases
the secret of
the secrecy of an offshore company or an
offshore trust
michael a question for you from rhonda
schwartz rhonda
michael we know you can't reveal sources
but this is an extraordinary effort to
crack one of the most secretive
industries offshore banking what can you
tell us about how the consortium was
able to get their hands on all these
documents
uh you know i can't tell you much i can
just tell you that over the years we
worked with lots of big leaks including
the panama papers
uh which had a very similar impact as
this current project and you know we
sort of built a track record icaj and
its partners have built a track record
being able to handle these these kind of
giant leaks protect our sources and and
break you know big and important news
and hit hard on these these kind of
issues so
these leaks came to us you know one of
the differences between um
the pandora papers and the panama papers
is uh quite simply the pandora papers
the the you know the new leak
is larger and more global than the
panama papers the panama papers involved
one law firm based in panama most
sacrament seca uh the pandora papers
involve
14
offshore providers law firms and other
kind of companies that set up offshore
structures for people uh really just
around the world from from the caribbean
to the uh
all the way to to the persian gulf uh to
the south china sea
michael i was struck by the fact that
there weren't quite as many americans as
i thought there might be
well
i i think
there there weren't as many as many
american
um
politicians
and those of course were many of the
headline names but there were definitely
a significant number of americans in
in in the the data
uh including robert durst the you know
the the the uh wealthy uh
uh entrepreneur made famous by his his
various legal legal troubles who was
recently convicted of murder in one of
the cases that has been sort of
you know tracking him for for many years
and and the other thing about the u.s
role is we found that um
the u.s is not simply a passive
participant in the offshore system
uh you know most people instead of
popular imagination you say offshore and
people think of like a palm fringed
island
and and definitely places like the
caymans and the british virgin islands
are are key cogs in the overall machine
but the truth is is that many of the
world's biggest banks many of the
world's biggest accounting firms many of
the world's biggest law firms in one way
or another participate in the system
represent clients who who are are using
the system and also the the united
states has its own sort of offshore
entities that aren't offshore to the
united states but they're right there in
in the heartland um you know
we we were able to uh look at more than
a dozen
states
uh in the u.s that that offer trusts
that foreign uh investors foreign
politicians and other folks uh if they
want to hide their money or protect
their money they come to the us and and
you know one of the biggest biggest
destinations is south dakota which has
turned itself into sort of a you know
caimans on the great plains of america
michael one final question it's often
been speculated that perhaps russian
president uh putin is one of the
wealthiest men if not the wealthiest in
the world who is the wealthiest man in
the world based on what you're seeing
you know i i think our documents i mean
it's definitely a big swathe of what's
going on in the world in terms of of
money being moved around but i don't
think we have enough uh to really say
like who who's the richest and and for
us
we work and you know of course we want
to write about the the mega wealthy
folks but for us what was most important
really was looking at the politicians
the folks who could actually you know
make a change
and and to some degree have the power to
end the offshore system or drastically
reign it in uh what they're doing so
we're you know in in our documents we
had uh 35 current and former world
leaders that's presidents
uh
prime ministers
uh and and of course the king of jordan
and then also overall we had about 300
more than 330
uh high-level uh public officials
including uh government ministers
ambassadors and then these heads of
state also
all right well michael hudson
congratulations on the investigative
work michael hudson a senior editor at
the international consortium of
investigative journalists thanks for
being with us
tonight thanks brian thanks rhonda
coming up next this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of mediaite
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of mediaite and we're joined by
aidan mclaughlin who's the editor in
chief of media which like the law and
crime trial network is part of the dan
abrams be the emperor and aiden we begin
with dana bash at cnn you've chosen her
as your winner
technology of course it has downsides
but it also has very powerful positive
effects
specifically about january 6th did the
algorithms that are in place
amplify pro-insurrection voices ahead of
january 6
yes or no
so quite the interview why was she
chosen as the winner aiden
right so that was dana bash on state of
the union on sunday interviewing nick
clegg a top executive at facebook who
has acted as a one of the top
spokespeople for the platform um the
interview has come in the wake of
disclosures from francis hagan a project
manager at facebook who has now turned
into a whistleblower she testified
before congress last week and called for
facebook to be regulated uh one of the
revelations from hagen uh the
whistleblower is that facebook helped
fuel the january 6 riot at the u.s
capitol
bash asked nick clegg about that on cnn
sunday and he failed to provide a clear
answer for whether or not facebook had a
role
in fueling these sort of this
misinformation uh and the organization
that led to that riot he basically said
that facebook has no answer as to
whether facebook played a role in the
attack um danabash pressed nick clegg
multiple times in the question uh and it
made the interview i'd say one of the
highlights of the sunday shows
holding his feet to the fire and for the
loser this week sharon waxman tell me
about her
right so the daily beast came out with a
new report over the weekend about sharon
waxman who is the founder and ceo of the
rap which is an entertainment and media
website that uh was launched in 2009.
the report found that sharon waxman runs
a toxic environment which has created a
culture of fear uh that's demoralizing
and degrading to staffers um so for
those who don't know the wrap uh is a
media and entertainment website uh
launched by waxman who's a veteran
journalist and she launched it to take
on the the big hollywood trade outlets
like variety deadline the hollywood
reporter um but this report from the
daily beast found pretty shocking
antidotes uh one was that she screamed
uh at a staffer who took his wife to the
oncologist
for a cancer treatment checkup there's a
number of other pretty shocking
allegations in the report
one of the
deputy editor
tom greer at the rap issued a comment
the daily beast where he accused uh some
of the sources that spoke to the daily
beast of working for jay penske who is a
rival media mogul to sharon waxman so
there's a little bit of a media
conspiracy theory in this as well um
brian but i think there's enough sources
on the record that you could say this is
a pretty solid report
all right aidan mclaughlin thank you so
much for being with us here tonight
and thanks to all you for joining us
we'll be back again next week and thanks
for a great team here at law and crime
for getting us on the air and off the
air
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you